so ist als nämlich hier ein der das
ganze prozedere hier zwei mal mitgemacht
hat und jetzt freundlicherweise auch zu
uns gekommen ist gerhard schröder
bundeskanzler ag schön dass sie da sind
freue mich sehr vielen dank für den
freundlichen empfang ich bin gerne
gekommen weil das für mich auch ein
bedeutender tag ist zum ersten mal nach
langer zeit wieder ein sozialdemokrat
als bundeskanzler und dabei zu sein zu
können dass heute dann doch wie viele
erinnerungen kommt ein plug-in heute an
98 oder das stimmt wenn man der
eidesleistung
seht dann kommen schon erinnerungen hoch
aber eher positive naja warum auch nicht
es gibt ja noch einen anderen punkt also
wie es ist hier viel von aufbruch von
fortschritt wagen die rede gewesen im
zusammenhang mit dem koalitionsvertrag
auch bei ihnen war rot-grün damals eine
premiere hatte es vorher nicht gegeben
auf bundesebene situation auch die ampel
ist neu ja das ist in der tat so dass
wird ja nicht einfach drei
unterschiedliche parteien zusammen zu
halten aber ich traue olaf scholz die
geduld aber auch die entschiedenheit zu
dass hinzugekommen und ich fand es auch
richtig dass er gesagt habe nehmen und
sollte auch an die nächste
legislaturperiode denken in der art und
weise wie man mit dem land umgeht aber
auch in der art und weise sieht man
kommunikation in dieser nicht ganz
einfachen koalitions
hinbekommen ja gleich mal klar machen
dass man weitermachen will auf jeden
fall wirklich ganz vielen vier jahres
ging an kuka eben dass er auch zu zu
gering und jetzt sicher interessant weil
sie von zukunft geredet haben beide
konstellationen sind ja
schon ab ob mit der spd wir hatten
sozial-liberale koalition wer hat eine
grüne koalition rot grüne koalition und
deswegen finde ich diese zusammensetzung
ganz
interessant auch was die perspektiven
angeht mehr liberalität in der
gesellschaft aber eben auch
verantwortung für umwelt und fürs klima
insbesondere und die spd wird sehr
deutlich machen dass sie den sozialen
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft für
wichtig und für notwendig die parteien
kennen sich sagen sie natürlich aus
unterschied aus anderen konstellationen
sie haben sich aber auch noch deutlich
verändert aber im vergleich zu früher
und insbesondere ihre spd hat sich
deutlich verändert muss man mal
feststellen denn das was wir die
vergangenen zwei jahre erlebt haben wie
geschlossen und wie konzentriert die spd
jetzt dieses wahlziel und jetzt auch
diese kanzlerkandidatur oder diesen
jetzt die kanzlerschaft von olaf scholz
angegangen ist das war ja im vergleich
zu den jahren davor doch einigermaßen
spektakulär erkennen sie ihre parteien
auch wieder doch natürlich wird auch
weiterhin streitlustig bleiben aber sie
hat und sie haben recht mit ihrer
bemerkung sie hat eingesehen dass
geschlossenheit und gemeinsames
auftreten wichtig ist wenn man wahlen
gewinnen will und die tatsache dass sie
mit olaf scholz einen sehr profilierten
kandidaten zur auswahl hatten der so gut
wie gar keine fehler gemacht hat werden
andere seine konkurrenten den einen oder
anderen fehler schon vorzuweisen haben
das danach und darüber hinaus die
parteiführung sich sehr diszipliniert
verhalten hat ist auch etwas was ich so
gar nicht unbedingt erwartet hatte was
aber zum sieg beigetragen hat und ich
gehe fest davon aus dass dieser
zusammenhalt dieser neue zusammenhalt
auch bleiben wird und die fraktion
deswegen diese regierung ja wollte und
auch tragen wird sie haben unter anderem
im zusammenhang mit der agenda 2010
erleben müssen wie schwierig ist auch
sein kann kanzler in einer koalition zu
sein jetzt haben wir ja viel von
zuversicht gesprochen von aufbruch wo
sind die risiken dieser konstellation
noch heute ist kein tag wo ich mich über
risiken auf regen oder gar darüber
nachdenke zunächst einmal sollte man der
regierung auch eine chance lassen das
was sie an programmen aufgestellt hat
umzusetzen und nicht von vornherein über
denkbare risiken sich unterhalten nein
ich möchte dass diese regierung erfolg
hat und dass insbesondere der
bundeskanzler erfolg hat und über
risiken reden wir dann wenn welche da
sind frage ja das frage ich was muss
worauf muss diese koalition 8 und damit
sie eine erfolgreiche wird auch welche
welche felder dass er kein geld aus
china welche aufgaben zum beispiel in
der außen und sicherheitspolitik man
muss europäischer in der
sicherheitspolitik denken man muss
vernünftige beziehungen zu china zu
russland
aufrechterhalten das wird ja nicht
einfach wenn man die erklärungen der
neuen außenministerin sich mal genau
anschaut also es gibt einen haufen
arbeit innen wie außenpolitisch zu tun
aber ich ganz sicher dass olaf scholz
genau weiß dass der bundeskanzler die
richtlinien der politik bestimmt so
steht es im grundgesetz und er wird es
machen höre ich ein klein wenig skepsis
an der zukünftigen aussenministerin
heraus annalena baerbock na ja das darf
ich obwohl die soweit ich informiert bin
gehört sie nicht zur spd also sie
bezweifeln schon ein klein wenig an dass
sie versuchen sie soll hat mich bezogen
auf äußerungen und ich gehört habe und
gelesen habe und das halte ich nicht für
unproblematisch was besonders naja
insbesondere das verhältnis zu china zu
russland aber auch die bemerkungen die
gemacht worden sind zur außenpolitik
insgesamt man kann ein land wie china
nicht isolieren das ist mitglied china
ist ein ständiges mitglied im
weltsicherheitsrat gleiche gilt für
russland und deutschland
braucht auch aus ökonomischen gründen
intakte beziehung und es wird sache auch
der außenministerin sein die aufrecht zu
erhalten und nicht nach dem motto
vorzugehen am grünen wesen soll die welt
genesen wie heikel wird dann die weitere
diskussion über nord stream zwei vor
diesem hintergrund weil sie seien die
branchen sowie ein genehmigtes projekt
und
ein solches projekt muss wirklichkeit
werden und das ist ganz einfach ich
würde mit ihnen gerne noch mal kurz auf
angela merkel gucken die leute hier
ihren letzten tag als kanzlerin hatte
ihr start war ich sag mal ein bisschen
holprig das hat sich deutlich verändert
sie hat ihre biografie mit vorgestellt
vor wenigen jahren da dann kann ich mich
erinnern wie bewerten sie als ihr
vorgänger ihre amtszeit heute und ich
sollte mich zurückhalten mit einer
bewertung das tue ich auch in der
öffentlichkeit aber
sie hat ein respektables ergebnis
vorzulegen das kann man doch gar nicht
bestreiten und das muss man auch nicht
bestreiten wird selbst wenn man
politisch gelegentlich unterschiedlicher
meinung ist es schön dass sie bei uns
gewesen sind wurden als kanzler ag und
uns noch mal ein bisschen einblick
gegeben haben wie werden sie noch
begleiten von diesem tag hier heute da
ich blocke begleitet vor allen dingen
meine frau das ist das wichtigste
vielen dank herr schröder und bei uns
geht es weiter mit gerd joachim von
verlor